a dangerous game of chicken as two
nuclear-armed leaders threatened to
destroy the other the war of words
between US president Donald Trump and
North Korean leader Kim jong-un is
beginning to shake even the most steady
of nerves recently Trump has rolled out
a new nickname for the North Korean
leader
Rocketman Kang jung-ho was a member of
the elite in North Korea and he worries
that mr. Trump crossed a line by getting
personal with Kim jong-un sparking the
first ever direct response from the
North Korean leader pledging Trump would
pay dearly for threatening his country
Kim jong-un is a god-like figure says
Kang and if the godlike figure says such
things to the u.s. it's not just going
to stay at words it needs to be put into
action that's what makes this situation
serious after a trump tweet over the
weekend that the North says it
interprets as a u.s. declaration of war
foreign minister ryeong Ho said Monday
North Korea is now within its rights to
shoot down u.s. bombers even if they
aren't in their airspace on Saturday
u.s. b-1b bombers flew further north of
the DMZ than any other time this century
a show of force that sparked a
propaganda video on the North Korean web
site with crude edits to show the u.s.
bombers being destroyed the video
claimed to be posted by an officer of
the kPa and North Korean military some
defectors have joined forces to show mr.
Trump they support his hardline stance
on North Korea
at a recent protest they pledged to join
a war of liberation to eliminate Kim
jong-un the hatred for the leader of
their home country is hard to miss this
defector activist tells me
South Korea tried to talk then Pyongyang
did another nuclear test so we have no
choice but to physically fight but the
vast majority in the region if not the
world wants peace security de-escalation
before words spill over into something
else once you provoke if you deescalate
you're worried about losing face and so
you know the United States is backing
itself into a corner here the North
Koreans
can stay in that corner I mean they've
lived in that corner for 70 years so for
now the insults of flying the threats of
fresh as the world waits for either
Trump or Kim to blink Paula Hancocks CNN
Seoul